foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video well my
friends the day is finally here HBO has
officially confirmed House of the Dragon
has begun filming for its second season
for those of you who don't know they
have been sharing this information all
over their social media they even gave
us our first look of the Iron Throne set
as filming is underway as you can see
House of the Dragons verified account
says it's time to go back to King's
Landing the second season of House of
the Dragon is now in production we
should start to see a hell of a lot more
photos and videos from their sets now
that filming has finally begun and as
I've always said before I will be here
releasing videos on everything that
happens during the making of the new
season this is when new information will
start to come out every day now that
everyone is back on set I will be
looking forward to discussing all the
new photos and videos that will leak out
from the sets as they're filming the
second season make sure you have already
subscribed in order to stay up to date
because there will be a lot more videos
heading your way now deadline's new
article says let them breathe fire
production has begun on House of the
Dragon season 2. filming is underway on
the HBO show at Warner Brothers Studios
leavesden with a first look photo
released of the Iron Throne sitting in
the Great Hall of the red key Ryan
Condell who is the co-creator and
showrunner said House of the Dragon has
returned we are thrilled to be shooting
again with members of our original
family as well as new talents on both
sides of the camera all of your favorite
characters will soon be conspiring at
the council tables marching with their
armies and riding their dragons into
battle get ready for the Game of Thrones
universe and fandom the shift gears as
we head into the second season although
we still have to wait until next summer
to see the show this is when things get
exciting and interesting again as new
information releases every day now we
already saw HBO's official photo from
the set of the Iron Throne however this
isn't the first image I've seen from the
new season we got our first glimpse of
one of the massive sets only a few days
ago over on Reddit the thanks to some
sneaky photographer they snapped a few
shots of one of the castles that will be
featured in House of the dragon's second
season now I happen to think this is
most likely the red keep in King's
Landing however there are some fans who
believe this might be another location
in Westeros I saw some fans saying this
might be Winterfell or harrenhal or even
rook's rest either way this was actually
our first look at what's happening
behind the scenes at House of the Dragon
soon enough we will see dragons flying
high overhead as the dance of the
Dragons finally begins get ready my
friends because all hell is about to
break loose this season as once again
everyone fights over the Iron Throne let
me know down below whose side are you on
the blacks or the greens also let me
know what you think about the new photos
and how excited you are for the filming
to begin on the new season as always I
want to thank everyone for watching this
video I hope all of you have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign